[Music]
everyone's favorite sassy sister from
the loud house can be such a mess
Lola is the girly spoiled beauty queen
of the loud house family stay tuned to
find out our favorite crazy Lola moments
hey loud house fans if you want to keep
up with all the best shows on TV be sure
to subscribe now let's get to the ten
moments that Lola was a total mess Lola
on guard duty
Lola obviously takes any role she is
given super seriously she is really
great and enforcing rules okay maybe she
is too good at it no guts no glory the
loud siblings are left at home alone
with Lori in charge but Lori is super
strict and the rest of the loud siblings
Ravel they decide Lincoln should be in
charge and tie up Lori Lincoln puts Lola
on guard duty and tells her not to let
anyone through the once Lincoln realizes
his sisters are crazy he decides he
needs Lori to regain control he goes to
free her but Lola refuses to let him
past she said no one gets through in the
boss's orders even though Lincoln gave
those orders she then takes it one step
too far
Lola knocks out her brother with a golf
club ouch that's just mean when Lincoln
wakes up he finds out that Lola has tied
him up just like Lori she threatens
anyone else who wants to try shenanigans
Lola is basically a tiny dictator
disguised as a pageant queen who we're
glad Lincoln got out so what finally
gets Lola to abandon her guard post
Lori throws a cloud of glitter
apparently sparkles are all Lola needs
to get distracted genius Lola's bet Lola
is a pretty girly girl so it makes total
sense that some of Lincoln's habits are
gross to her she really hates that
Lincoln likes to lounge around and read
comic books in his underwear she tries
to make him stop but he points out that
all of the siblings have bad habits
Lola makes a bet that they can give up
all their bad habits
if the girls win Lincoln can never read
in his underwear again but if Lincoln
wins Lola has to buy him a new pair of
undies all the other sisters break under
pressure pretty quickly but Lola resists
the urge to look in the mirror
at her appearance her makeup is smeared
all over like a psychotic clown it's
terrifying when the bed is down to just
her and Lincoln she tries to force him
to take off his sweatpants but then she
catches a glimpse of her terrible makeup
job
Lincoln thinks he's won but they all
forgot about baby Lilly she never cried
so the girls technically won the bet but
lo the redeems herself she buys Lincoln
a new pair of underwear and says that
it's only fair that he continue his bad
habit since everyone else does okay
maybe Lola isn't all bad after all
Lola the criminal Lincoln causes a world
of trouble and butterfly effects when he
knocks down Lisa's science experiments
with his yo-yo he decides not to tell
her what happened but this starts a
butterfly effect where weird things
happen to all of the sisters and the
family breaks apart Linney ends up
smarter than Lisa who runs off to work
at a gas station Lori goes skydiving
with Clive and Lola Paloma gets hit in
the face with a soccer ball and goes
total drama queen she believes her
swollen nose makes her look like a
monster as she runs upstairs she falls
down and all her teeth fall out she
declares that her beauty pageants career
is over
Lincoln tries to convince her that it's
not that bad but she packs up and leaves
and gets even more maimed in the process
later we find out that Lola and Lynne
have turned to a life of crime they
robbed Lisa's gas station and lead the
police on the slow speed chase through
the desert and Lola's Kitty car Lola is
just so dramatic there's a lot more to
life than beauty pageants but she just
doesn't see that the whole episode is
just pretty hilarious whoo we're just
glad Lincoln decides to fess up to his
original accident so none of this
craziness actually happens Lola the
pageant queen
Lola may be a twin but she and Lana
could not be more different Lola is as
girly as they come Lana is a tomboy who
likes taking huge risks and loved gross
things in toads and Tiaras Lincoln is
training Lola for a new pageant the
prize is two season passes
to Dairyland which he really wants but
lola trips on a perfume bottle and
breaks her hand and leg lincoln decides
to train Lana to take Lola's place but
they can't let Lola know when they
imagine how Lola would react to an
impersonator they picture a terrifying
demon version of Lola and honestly
that's a pretty fair assessment Lola has
such a temper and she loves beauty
pageants this can't end well
Lincoln tries to Trey and Lana but she
just can't hide her normal personality
her talent is elbow farting after all
when Lola finds out she goes after
Lincoln she is so angry it's scary
she thinks Lincoln has ruined her
pageant career she's more than a little
dramatic at this point but then Lana
shocks everyone by winning the judges
loved that she was totally different
Lola lets her twin keep the winning
tiara he did win and I respect a winner
but we bet they never try to
double-cross her again Lola the
tattletale okay we all know Lola has a
reputation as a tattletale and a lot of
secur do but in one episode in
particular Lola turns her tattletale
habits into straight-up blackmail
maybe that life of crime from the
butterfly effect who wasn't so far a
face in the toddler's tail Lola finds
out all the siblings have a secret Club
to confess their darkest secrets but
they won't let her in because she always
tells on them Lola eavesdrops and uses
their secrets to get what she wants out
of them
she makes Lincoln be her Butler during a
tea party by threatening to tell her dad
that Lincoln broke his disco ball she
uses her blackmail to get Lucy to drive
her princess car so Lola can practice
her pageant wave she gets Luna to give
up her seat on the couch she even gets
Lori to stop texting and scratch Lola's
head by swearing to tell their parents
that Lori scratched the van
she manipulates all ten siblings this
way this is one scary six-year-old
eventually they get back at Lola by
discovering a secret about her Lola
reveals she only wanted to be included
because she felt left out cuz all I
really wanted was to be included in your
group we can totally understand that but
blackmail it's never the answer
Lola Lola
z1 it takes a pretty special vehicle to
drive around the family the size of the
loud family the Louds have vans illa
which has been passed down to their dad
from his grandfather seriously how does
that thing still run in Fantastic Voyage
vans illa breaks down the loud kids have
to push it while their mom steers in the
driver's seat but Lola is such a diva
she refuses to help her siblings push it
at all instead she stands on top of the
van and waves like she's in a parade
with drama queen but her dramatic
tendencies backfire she got stuck in a
tree branch three blocks from home she
has to walk the rest of the way home
with two black eyes and covered in twigs
the kids try to get their dad to get a
new van they convince him but he turns
into a total meanie
according to Lola he basically won't let
them ride in the van at all finally they
decide to get ven Zilla back they have
to search a junkyard and push the van
home once again
Lola stands on top and waves instead of
helping because that tree branch didn't
teach her much of a lesson Lola the bald
sister all of the loud siblings are
really demanding which is why Lorri
tries to move into the garage in the
episode GarageBand they always need
something from her and she never gets
much gratitude
especially from Lola at the beginning of
the episode
Lola demands that Lorri brush her hair
to get the tangles out she has some
serious Bed Head but it's so tangled
that Lorri accidentally hurts Lola Lola
yells then she hangs up on Lori's
boyfriend's Bobby how rude but karma
came back and got Lola later in the
episode she is still trying to get all
the tangles out of her hair lisa says
she has a special formula to get the
tangles out but we all know how Elise's
experiments go Lola is left totally bald
and Lisa said she should have specified
that she wanted to keep her hair but
we're pretty sure that's implied Lisa
Lola gets so angry she says that it
never would have happened if Lori had
been there at least she finally started
to appreciate her oldest sister she
wears a wig and has
or detangle that when Laurie moves back
in Lola the Queen looma has a tendency
to be extra AF and that is definitely
the case in the episode mall of duty in
this episode Lincoln wants to go to the
mall
bitey is watching his younger sisters so
he decides to take them all to the mall
that seems like a terrible idea
does he know how much trouble is sisters
get into when he loses his sisters he
finds Lola at Prince's palace she is
sitting on a throne and has declared
herself a queen that Q's making all of
the other kids act as her minions when
Lincoln tries to make her leave she
threatens to send him to the dungeon
luckily this isn't Lincoln's first rodeo
with Lola he knows exactly what to say
to get her out of princes palace he
tells her there is another girl outside
who is claiming to be a more powerful
queen than Lola she just can't have that
she gets off her throne and says hikes
it's probably a good thing Lola doesn't
actually rule the kingdom she'd be a
terrifying ruler she orders all the
other kids to take care of her Kingdom
later she gives Lincoln a 9 out of 10 as
her babysitter she is such a diva Lola
the mean sister
none of the loud siblings are perfect
and that's what makes the show so great
they can all be mean sometimes like in
the episode no such luck
after Lincoln starts going to Lin's
tournaments the team begins losing Flynn
calls him bad luck and Lincoln muses
that River to get out of going to his
sister's events but then he gets too
left out
we know Lola can be super dramatic about
stuff like this when Lincoln offers to
go to her pageant she sprays him with
hairspray and Tully goes away she
screams at him to go away later the
whole family wants to go to a movie but
they won't that Lincoln come because of
his bad luck
Lola tells him the whole movie could
sell out if he shows up then when he is
forced outside and finds out he can't go
to the beach
Lola tells him he is bad luck and shuts
the doggie door on him okay
that's just mean Lola is definitely a
hyung
addition to the loud house which moment
when Lola is being totally extra is your
favorites let us know in the comments
those are the 10 hilarious times when
Lola loud was a total mess be sure to
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]